hisoka is one of the most mysterious
characters not just in Hunter Hunter but
in anime and marker in general to the
point where most sentences using hisoka
as a subject have a tendency to end in a
question mark and my question to that is
why because we have so much more
information about hisoka than you may
realize which even extends into a highly
detailed backstory we know how he
learned Nan and who he learned Nan from
we also know the very first person he
ever killed using bungee gum and so so
much more however none of that is
actually in Hunter Hunter itself
although to be fair to Togashi that
isn't too unusual for example that's how
we got krapika's detailed backstory
after all in a special two chapter
volume although here's a fun fact about
hisoka that is in the manga hisoka's
last name is Moro not a lot of people
know that because it's only revealed in
the manga in chapter 351 when his full
name was announced in Heaven's Arena but
also hisoka is one of the few characters
who is spoken of directly by the
narrator hisoka never speaks of his past
he's not particularly interested in
events on gone he'll probably forget
what Castro looks like by tomorrow
hisoka does not belong to anything or
anyone hisoka is his own man and he's
confident that he is the most powerful
and of course the narrator would have
had to say this because he so can never
would have because he has no interest in
himself hisoka is interested in others
which makes him one of those brilliant
Wild Card characters because you can't
classify him as something simple like
good or evil or even mostly good or
mostly evil even antagonist or
protagonist there are times in Hunter
Hunter where he soak a slip seamlessly
between those roles and as a result he
has a tendency to collect Pinnacle
professions like their trading cards for
example he's a professional Hunter a
floor master of Heaven's Arena and was
also a member of the Phantom Troupe the
only character in the series to have
attained all three of those absurdly
high-paying jobs although in terms of
perception hisoka falls on the scarier
side due to his battle lost for which he
often gets labeled probably quite
rightly as a murderer sociopath fighting
is literally the only reason why hisoka
lives and fighting worthy opponents is
also the only reason reason why he ever
does anything that isn't that this is
because he soaked her experiences what
seems to be a quite literal orgasm as a
result of near-death experiences in one
case as a result of just flat out dying
so he's on this constant quest to find
new and more powerful opponents to bring
him to that Brink a quest which much
like he in battle only continues to get
harder as time goes on he is
legitimately one of the most powerful
characters in Hunter Hunter and so for
hisoka this world is starting to run dry
so hisoka is at the point where he's
cultivating the power of other
characters and this is where hisoka
becomes is a little bit weird to think
about to say the least over the course
of Hunter Hunter a lot of his plotline
can be summarized as grooming children
essentially so that they can grow up to
give him an orgasm like it's not sexual
but also it is it really is and hisoka
is what would be referred to as a switch
he often exhibits very feminine
characteristics and uses female specific
speech in Japanese as if in an attempt
to come across a submissive and alluring
even though a grand total of zero people
see it that way but he absolutely does
not hesitate to switch it up and become
dominant when the time is right as far
as more traditional feelings go hisoka
does have a thing for machi who is the
only character he's shown a non-combat
sexual attraction towards he's even
invited her out for dinner and implied
intercourse although she rejected him
but hisoka also has an on-again
off-again relationship with illumi
zoldik hisoka often teams up with him
but it's not going well illumi has more
or less friend zone hisoka battle-wise
and probably every otherwise but hisoka
does plan to take illumi on one day one
day very soon actually but hisoka's true
love in the series is leader of the
Phantom troop chrolo Lucifer crolo is
absolutely the one with the perfect mix
of intelligence power and a genuine
desire to brutally kill murder hisoka
which he did do that that one time but
the problem is he soak his abilities are
designed to be so Sly and versatile he
is of course the user of Bungee gum
transmuted aura that contains the
properties of both Rubber and gum but he
also comes equipped with an often
forgotten amount secondary ability
called extra surprise which possesses no
straightforward combat utility in fact
it's very rarely used by hisoka in
combat at all and we do actually have an
explanation for how and why he created
texture surprise but first against
weaker opponents you know those unlikely
to bring him to climax hisoka still
likes to fight but he does so with style
for example his match against Castro is
one of the rare cases of him wielding
texture surprise in combat where hisoka
purposely crafted the illusion that he'd
reattached his arm I can't stress this
enough hisoka did not need to do this
the narrator even said that using
texture surprise was not at all critical
to his victory but it was critical to
hisoka because fighting isn't about the
pun intended outcome it's about the
experience hisoka constructed the most
fun possible experience out of Castro
but why is he like this well if you want
to retain the mystery that is hisoka
then this might be a good point to stop
watching the video because we're about
to go into details he's a character who
is seen as akin to the joker as in the
less you know about him the better it's
the mystery that makes him that much
more terrifying and one key thing we do
understand is that bungee gum is a name
taken from his favorite brand of chewing
gum and texture surprise is also taken
directly from another popular in-world
candy that came with novelty stickers
hence why hisoka's texture surprise
takes the form of stickers other than
that though Hunter Hunter gives you
absolutely nothing about hisoka's past
but that doesn't mean it doesn't Exist
Elsewhere with the approval of Hunter
Hunter author yoshihiro tagashi a hisoka
backstory was illustrated by shui Ishida
this is a One-Shot chapter called
hisoka's past and the story opens up
with a much younger hisoka being found
on the verge of death by a man named
mauritonia The Ring Master of the
mauritano troop we don't know how hisoka
came to be in such bad condition he just
was but chronologically this is the
earliest known depiction we have of
hisoka he was found in Glam Gasland
which is a city on the European
continent Northeast of York New City
those who originally settled there
became unbelievably Rich due to all of
the natural gas resources but eventually
all of those were depleted after which
point they turned the city into a Las
Vegas style entertainment destination
hence why the mauritonia troop were here
they were trying to make it big time in
whatever the circus equivalent of Big
Time Is Now mauritonio himself had a
very special act that he would perform
called Sky swimming it bewildered most
but it was actually a very simple use of
net lykisoka mauritonia was a transmuter
and so he gave his ore magnetic
properties thus allowing him to walk on
any surface and Maur Antonio essentially
took pity on hisoka and took him in when
they found him on the ground luckily by
this age hisoka was able to perform card
tricks not only that but he could
perform them even better than mauritonia
himself hisoka said that he learned them
from his mother and that she was a quote
very skillful lady which may imply that
hisoka was raised in gam glass land
because of its high
have I been saying it it's supposed to
be gas glamland which may imply that
hisoka was actually raised in gas clam
land since it has such a high focus on
performance was I saying Glam Gasland
although there's a stranger t with
hisoka's last name as well Moro well
specifically that his full name is
stated in the Western Way rather than
the Japanese way which would be Moro
hisoka and the only other characters
that do this tend to be people from
meteor City such as fate and Porter but
also hisoka's name is spelled in
Katakana further implying for An Origin
now most of the mauritonia troop were
quite rare if hisoka and to be fair they
had good reason to be because even at
this early age he was already displaying
the behaviors that he's best known for
in Hunter Hunter now at the same time
there was a notorious serial killer
running loose in gas clam land called
hundred-faced John Doe named because he
would use a different face for every
attack which seems very coincidental
this mysterious boy appears on the floor
in the city at roughly the same time as
a notorious serial killer and we know
that said mysterious boy later grows up
to become something quite akin to a
serial killer with abilities that are
quite similar to what the serial killer
is using so it's intriguing at this time
hisoka was only adding to suspicion by
actively usurping the roles of others
within mauritonia's troop notably
replacing their juggler and putting him
to such shame that the juggler quit the
industry altogether a very important
moment here occurred though because the
first time hisoka goes on stage is when
he first daunts his trademark star and
tear makeup implying that in the modern
day he wears that when he's ready to
perform just doing less juggling and
more murdering but due to hisoka's Raw
potential mauritonio decided to train
him in the use of nen he was hisoka's
Gateway into Aura control and they
practiced nen once a week together and
as time goes by we learn that
mauritonio's original ambition was to
become a professional Hunter he even
took the hunter exam but he failed in
that particular year it was said that
only one person passed the exam and this
is implied to be the 367th hunter exam
where the only candidate to pass was
Jing freaks one of maritonia's troop
members of baki even wanted to become a
professional Hunter to fulfill
mauritonia's desire and he was also
actively training abakian nen because
she was the only other person with
enough potential for and she'd been
training for years at this point mind
you so it was a bit of a shock when
within a single week hisoka mastered
both ten and ren showing the same if not
greater potential than gone and kilwa
which was said to be one in a million
for some contrast here mauritonio
estimated that it would take hisoka
around three years to reach this point
to reach this point which he did in one
week so at this stage it only adds more
suspicion to hisoka being the nun serial
killer as his progress is so
astoundingly fast it's almost as if he's
Faking It although this suspicion is
immediately quelled when hisoka saves
abaki from John Doe and being the
sociopathic Little Genius he is hisoka
almost instantly introduces but John Doe
is actually mauritonia and mauritonio
himself turns out to be quite
disturbingly similar to hisoka
mauritonio gets a rush from performing
from surprising people although in his
case it's a rush he cannot quell until
he kills someone reveals that he only
joined martonio's troop for the very
cryptic reason of wanting to draw the
right card so it wasn't for mauritonia
or I guess John Doe specifically but he
turned out to be exactly what hisoka was
looking for much like how he would go on
to do with crolo and the Phantom troop
but by this point hisoka had developed
too rapidly he had his own inability
bungee gum and he wielded its World
Premiere Performance to kill mauritonia
however hisoka took more inspiration for
mauritonia and using mauritonia's trick
to transmute himself new faces he so
could developed texture surprise an
ability that was stated to be brought
into existence purely as a passing whim
which he used to give maartonio one of
the John Doe killer faces the
implication here being quite
extraordinary this implies that hisoku
is so talented that he could if he
desired develop a legion of nine
abilities just like that just on a whim
but he doesn't because bungee gum and
texture surprise currently satisfy all
of his whims but if they didn't if
hisoka found a new desire then he would
become that more dangerous instantly
after this hisoka and all traces of
martinio disappear and the story ends
with the troop wondering where they both
went now there is some question as to
whether the story is Canon or not and
currently that's very much up to you as
the reader an official statement has
never been made but it was created with
togashi's approval although one curious
fun fact is that this project was
originally an April Fool's joke so we
issued a posted the idea on his Twitter
as a gag back in 2015. so it's a joke
come to life it could be the truth or it
could be like the Joker telling one of
the many stories about how he got his
scars and even though it explains a lot
it still leaves so many questions how
did hisoka get beaten up in the
beginning well that was almost certainly
a ruse conducted by him to get into the
mauritonia troop but why was he even
after the trip to begin with was he on
the hunt to fight John Doe and this is
where his instincts led him or was he
just looking for a fight and Drawn to
this place by some force that even he
couldn't describe I would also even
question was hisoka looking for a fight
at all his desire here is so unclear
that I personally don't think that even
hisoka had a solid idea of exactly what
he wanted he only knew what it was when
he found it he also clearly already has
a past with performance as he was able
to do Advanced card tricks and circus
tricks with no effort whatsoever but
with that I also have to think was what
he said about his mother even the truth
I'd honestly even question whether or
not he already knew about nen and he was
just pretending putting on a performance
within a performance as he often does
but the only reason why I wouldn't go
that far is because there is a scene
with him in private in a bath
experimenting with his new abilities and
developing bungee gun but forget whether
this one shot is Canon or not let's
assume that it is even if it was is
anything that his soccer actually says
or does in this one shot true because
those are two very different questions
but it does lay a lot of foundation for
Hunter Hunter though one curious
question that's always lingered is why
hisoka took the hunter exam the answer
that hisoka gives netro is that so he
can legally kill people but in this
context it would be because he learned
about it from mauritonia and neglected
to mention this but by the way the
reason why mauritonio never took the
exam again is because he was scarred
from the candidate implied to be Jing
mentally Scott not physically Scott
although that may be physically Scott we
never see his true face because he
always changes the faces but that idea
would have excited hisoka so then he
goes and takes a hunter exam himself and
it's just boring so boring that he goes
and murders 20 of his fellow examinees
which is not against the rules but he
also almost killed an examiner which is
against the rules and he does kill said
examiner in the next year but the blue
balls must have been strong he took his
relationship with gone also becomes a
lot more interesting because of
mauritano's relationship to Jing hisoka
essentially sought out Jing or a jinglak
opponent after hearing of the hunter
exam and what he found was gone hisoka
then recognized that potential and
decided to raise gone into a jing hisoka
once gone to become the same sort of
person that was capable of scarring
mauritonia this story also informs
hisoka's relationship with crolo as well
he's also a troop leader after all but
of a troop that hisoka has a much more
vested interest in activity wise and
this could be hisoka potentially looking
for and try trying to recreate his
experience with mauritonia he even got
to the point where he and crolo did
fight in Heaven's Arena the spectacle
very much befitting hisoka's taste even
if crolo was the one who chose the arena
and it was here that hisoka received his
most powerful orgasm yet not only
fighting but literally being killed by
crolo in Heaven's Arena however hisoka's
lust for battle was so strong and
actually dying you know it doesn't serve
us that so his desire to live was so
strong that he programmed bungee gum to
revive him after death and he now exists
in a state of post-mortem Nan acting as
a seductive gum-based Terminator on a
mission to kill each and every member of
the Phantom Troupe and that is currently
all there is to the existence of hisoka